you
in the fires
[Music]
this is firestorm battlefield fives new
battle royale experience the fight for
survival across land air and sea
firestorm brings the biggest map ever to
the Battlefield franchise an immense
sandbox ten times bigger than Hamada
from battlefield 5 only with battlefield
signature gunplay visuals combat
vehicles and destructible environments
this is a world dominated by the
firestorm a deadly ring of fire that
destroys everything in its path fleeing
on foot isn't your only option with 17
vehicles available and firestorm
launches you'll have a range of choices
to navigate the battlefield
whether you're rolling in heavy armor
cruising in a swim parka or patrolling
the skies with a prototype helicopter
there are a range of vehicles to help
you travel faster and fight off enemies
gear up
as you travel almond rare and epic
weapons gadgets and armor are scattered
across the map if you are downed in a
firefight you can be revived by
teammates and new to firestorm squeeze
off some rounds in a last act of Defense
although not all loot is just lying
around strong boxes and safes have some
of their best items if you're willing to
take the risk
vehicle lock ups have the rarest land
vehicles in firestorm and working
together will open them faster breakout
the combat vehicle and you might have an
advantage but remember they can be
countered by anti-vehicle weaponry and
gas
complete a resupply point objective and
you'll be rewarded with rare or epic
loot for the squad these won't be easy
to obtain
watch for the barrels balloons and you
could snag a Supply Drop
artillery strike v1 rocket and even
attack
this world is a sandbox and every
victory is unique as the firestorm
shrinks your squad will have to adapt to
each new situation to become the last
one standing
[Music]
by Xbox one get battlefield 5